افاد مراسل الجزيره بتحليق للطيران الحربي
في سماء الخرطوم صباح اليوم بينما سمع دوي
انفجارات وسط العاصمه وشرق الخرطوم بحري
وكانت معارك داريا قد اندلعت امس الخميس
في محيط القياده العامه وسط الخرطوم في
اشتباكات وصفت بالاعنف منذ بدء الازمه
التي تنهي اليوم اسبوعها الثالث في هذه
الاثناء اعلنت قوه الدعم السريع موافقتها
على تمديد الهدنه لمده 72 ساعه اضافيه
وذلك استجابه لوساطه امريكيه سعوديه وقال
الدعم السريع في بيان ان موافقته على
تمديد الهدنه جاءت من اجل فتح الممرات
الانسانيه وتسهيل حركه المواطنين
والمقيمين وتمكينهم من الوصول الى مناطق
امنه
وهذه الصور تاتينا مباشره من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم
مع من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره هيثم اويت
هيثم كيف بدا الوضع في الخرطوم بعد هذه
المعارك الشرسه
هذا الوضع الان في الخرطوم هناك نسمع ذوي
اصوات لي انفجارات خاصه في منطقه الخرطوم
بحري حيث تتصاعد اعمده الدخان الكثيف من
تلك المنطقه حاليا في اشاره الى ان هناك
ما تزال المواجهات محتدمه وسلاح الجو
التابع للجيش السوداني يقوم بتنفيذ عمليات
في هذه الاثناء لاهداف تابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع طبعا هذه التطورات تاتي بعد يوم
طويل وكان شاقا بالامس من مواجهات عنيفه
جرت في في ذات المدينه ايضا في ذات
المواقع كانت هناك اعنف المواجهات في خلال
النهار ومساء يوم امس او الان تتواصل هذه
العمليات فيما يبدو في تلك المنطقه بعد
هدوء تاتي هذه المواجهات طبعا بعد ان اعلن
كل الطرفين التزامهما وقبولهما بالهدنه
المعلنه سواء كانت الهدنه التي جاءت من
قبل منظمه الايجاد وقبلت بها القوات
المسلحه الجيش واول هدنه التي تقول قوات
الدعم السريعه انها قبلت بها بوساطه
امريكيه السعوديه لمده 72 ساعه وطبعا مده
مهله الايجاد هي تمتد لي سبعه ايام هذه هي
المواجهات تاتي في ظل ساحه السياسيه ما
تزال تنادي وتتباين رؤىها حول الحل
النهائي لهذه المشكلات وهذه المواجهات
المستمره ولكنها تتفق في ان الحرب لابد ان
تقف هذه المواجهات وان يتم وقف لاطلاق
النار وخفض لهذا التصعيد المستمر ايضا مع
تنامي الضغط الدولي المتواصل سواء كان من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه او من الدول
الاقليم المحيطه الاقليمي منظمات الاجات
الاتحاد الافريقي دول الجوار او من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا الاليه الثلاثيه
الامم المتحده او الايجارات والاتحاد
الافريقي هذه هذا الحراك يستمر في ونحن
الان ننه الاسبوع الثالث من هذه المواجهات
وعلى اعتاب دخول الاسبوع الرابع ما تزال
الانعكاسات المتواصله لهذا الصراع يعني
تتوالى في اماكن عديده هناك ايضا اشتباكات
بالامس في مدينه الابيض حضرت شمال كردفان
وايضا هناك مخاوف من ان تنعكس هذه
الصراعات في الكثير من المواقع خاصه في
ولايات دارفور اوضاع الانسانيه المترديه
كلها جمله من تلقي بالمخاوف على مستقبل
هذا الصراع ومقالاته شكرا لك هيثم اويت
مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من الخرطوم